okay uh
this is another classic
mistake that i make in this banter blitz
sessions
is that i try to accept
a username that i find somewhat amusing
uh and this is gustafson gambit
1300 from bulgaria but what happens is
that you i usually make this mistake
that i see username that i i that i find
amusing and then it turns out
that i that i played them before and
usually
i try to mostly play people that i
haven't
played before in order to give
as many uh a chance as possible to play
in these
um but there you go
um it happens from it happens from time
to time
and at least my opponent gets the chance
for a revenge because i could see
um that
i'd won the previous game
surprisingly enough um
not too much to say about the opening
he's chosen
uh somewhat rare line here with um
uh with with the queen takes d4 instead
of knight xt4
which is reasonable i think
you're not gonna you're not gonna get an
advantage as white but
i don't think you're gonna be be worse
either just gonna have
a pretty uh normal game
i think bishop d2 was a little bit
careful uh careless though
um since i do get knight g4
attacking the queen this is why in these
lines
you very often go h3 as soon as possible
just to cover
cover the square on g5 so sorry on g4
so you never have to worry about that
particular jump
and finally after knight g4 queen d3
knight b4 would have actually trapped
his queen
in the middle of the board uh but after
queen g5 which is the best move he does
have the square on h4
so he's he's as well as f4 so he's
pretty
pretty safe but now i do get a double
attack on
f2 and also b2 which hopefully
will pay some
sort of sort of dividends
um queen b2
rook b1 then if queens d2
rook c1 my queen is
i think quite certainly just
just trapped i don't think there are any
any tricks there
but i can go queen
queen a3 after rook b1
then there's rook b7 bishop c3
rook d7 knight f6
well i do have bishop h6 though
okay i'll go for that
looks looks a lot better actually
he does have the option of going knight
d5 now
and if bishop g5 knight b6 bishop d2
there's knight d7
i think he comes out on top there
[Music]
um yeah
after queen d5 i should probably try and
win
another another tempo with the
knight of six truth be told after queen
b6 this whole
operation didn't didn't
i think achieved much most probably
so um
yeah um quinn d3
now i spoke about earlier that night
before traps the queen
after queen d3 now it doesn't trap the
queen
but it does leave him in a world of
trouble
um queen d4 is the only decent square
for the queen
and then queen takes d4 knight takes d4
and
the bishman d2 will hang leaving me with
an extra bishop
and uh knight a4 is ingenious probably
the best try there was bishop e3 in
order not to lose immediately
even there after knight d3 bishop b6
knight takes b2 um
i would have at least won a couple of
pawns um
[Music]
as some strange lines they're going like
bishop a5 b6 bishop eight
bishop b4 a5 bishop a3
rook takes c3 bishop xb2 rook takes c2
then bishop takes f6
he may not have lost a piece there but i
think he was still losing a couple of
puns
uh here uh however he does save his
queen but
um but
um yeah full pieces
is lost through queen a3 it's just
important that i i trade on
on d2 first um now of queen a4
i just moved the bishop back and i'm i'm
a clear
clear knight up here
after knight c2 there are a number of
options uh sorry knight d2
knight c2 queen a4 um
[Music]
qui rook uh sorry knight a1 rook a1
queen b2
r281 doesn't seem to win on the spot so
i'll just grab the pawn with the bishop
instead
knight c4 i think can be met very
easily with queen c5 everything's
everything's well protected
and um yeah from
from here on on it should be
rarely fairly simple uh grabbing another
pawn
but i wouldn't say queen c3 was a
mistake because
that pawn could not be protected anyway
let's just go d5 now winning yet another
pawn he has to move the knight i will
trade queens and then and then
uh grab another pawn actually as a
matter of fact after
95 i might have gone
might have gotten queen d6 and queen g3
rook c2 winning a pawn that way
a3 think i'm gonna go
knight c2 again attacking the rook
a1 as well as um
still threatening the knight in c4
um yeah c4
this doesn't really help i just move the
queen
rook c1 is probably best but then
um here i just take the take the rook
no need to
no need to make it any more difficult
than it is
um 94 is also coming here
and that's going to be a rook and three
pawns
up and
this is uh we're getting into now
now you resign kind of territory
the clock situation also not helping
queen b6 setting up a possible smothered
mate
and here after
um is there any immediate win here
i don't know we'll just go queen f6
attacking the
rook and i won um
yeah quincy for
this move loses so so many pieces it's
hard to even count them
but
there there was nothing there for him
anyway so
again doesn't make a whole lot of a lot
of difference
we'll give a check he's gonna lose some
time
okay